bonjour bonjour quelle est la recette du
jour maïté en appel charles 10 et
pourquoi se le dise je ne sais pas vous
savez pas non mais moi tout ce que je
sais c'est que c'est un vieux papiers
jaunis on l'a trouvé au fond d'une
armoire à la campagne et on a trouvé que
la recette avait l'air très bonne avec
tout ce qu elle est dedans on a eu envie
d'essayer
ah ben voilà c'est plus ça nous a permis
d'avoir fait superbe invités mais qui
sont bons c'est une race extraordinaire
armes rares à ce sont les deux lapins de
votre survie
oui qu'on ne va pas tuer n'ayez pas peur
voilà on va tout de suite rassuré tous
les végétariens ils vont continuer à
vivre très heureux dans un bel et rial
sous les chênes dans la forêt landaise
et puis nous parce que pour ceux qui ne
sont pas végétariens on peut manger du
lapin on en a prévu un tournant a prévu
un autre qui n'est pas de la même
famille n'ont pas de drame tout va bien
alors pour faire le lapin charles delys
il vous faut quoi et b ne faut pas mal
de petites choses il nous faut de
l'armagnac
il nous faut un bon petit vin rouge il
nous faut des poires des pruneaux des
raisins secs qui sont trempés dans
l'armagnac
il nous faut mavs en crèche de la
ballerine del moral a dû l'armée gagnon
et de l'ail
il nous faut du thym du laurier il me
faut bien entendu un lapin et des
champignons de paris
voilà et puis ses deux frères et soeurs
ses frères et soeurs ou sept frères et
soeurs ses deux frères et soeurs on va
aller les ramener dans leur jolie blonde
à côté d'ici fait votre soeur bien à
l'air pur et nous on va commencer à
travailler oui
par quoi commence ton irrité par des
coupes et d'autre la peine alors le
hachoir
oui on met directement dans la cocotte
vous avez mis quoi dans la cocotte de
l'huile de l'huile trajet rue ou de
règle jusqu'en web et quand vous dites
de l'huile ou de la grèce c'est bien
entendu de la graisse de canard de chez
vous exact des landes
oui alors vous continuez à le prouver et
là je vais en rêvait le fois parce que
le faut on va en avoir besoin
le fou allait le mettre de côté bien
soigneusement le faut elles s'en vont en
avoir besoin
en losange lehbila avec un peu de
vinaigre également là pour ne pas qu'il
caille
et on va continuer là vous avez les
revenus rossi d'audience à ses prébendes
voulait laisser dedans bien sûr
et alors et l'on transforme oxala pour
salzbourg quoi maïté vous êtes obligé de
l'église est presque à chaque fois non
au revoir non voilà et là vous savez pas
tout de suite
oui il ya main tendue a toujours pareil
ça grésille comme il faut excellent
et qu'est ce que vous allez ajouter
après la longue lettre l'oignon 1 vous
la balle parce que l'oignon c'est
beaucoup plus long à cuire comme la
fonde en rien la seconde parce que c'est
une centre partenaire fiable et l'ail
écrasé vous avez les gousses d'ail sur
le côté 3 gousses d'ail et d'un bel
oignons c'était assez faim ou cartons de
bière
je vais vous trouviez le tour là et en
or si vous avez préparé de la ventrèche
comme on dit toujours non j'ai pas pour
rien non plus lancé bavant de pêche
voilà c'est comme ça que je l'appelle
ici pour faire des petits lardons afin
de lâcher cinq volets qui finissent de
voulait couper le temps que vous alliez
voir que ça va bien dans la marmite ça
va aller ça se fait ça fait face au coût
n'est ce pas willy tranquille le nom
vient tranquillement ça suit son cours
voilà voilà ça y est tout ça va et dans
la marmite évidemment et donner des bons
groupes
alors je vais mettre maintenant mon
bouquet garni
bien sûr avec le laurier le thym le
persil a rien de cerfeuil qui doit être
caché dedans tout ce qu'il faut pour les
bambous et ensuite d epuis tout pâle et
pis je vais commencer à mettre un petit
peu de gingembre que je vais y grimper
dira que c'est comme une racine
indifférence qu'ont les envies c'est du
frais ses meilleurs
we've alentours vont retrouver ça donne
un petit goût citronné vous avez c'est
d'expliquer mais pas en être trop parce
que ça a des conséquences qui te fait
quelques fois quittant dont la femme
dont le mari de la femme à la rend
amoureux conduire légalement exactement
d'envoyer leurs beaux fous et voilà
et puis ça on a un petit bâton on est
rarement mis comme ça mais en fait je
crois que c'est de la graine elle ne
raterait mène à tout et vous alors
lecouffe nom et qui savent très bien
c'est sa part tu me to diana sais pas ce
que ça donne un goût assez fort il a
fortement et j'ai remarqué vous serez
invités dans les recettes anciennes par
exemple dictionnaire de dumas ya
toujours énormément d'efforts dans sa
salle à manger et après ça il va bien
falloir que vous le mouillé avec quelque
chose où il y avait de tout bouillon il
a montré moi ça voilà c'est à bouillon
que vous avez fait comme tous les ans
avec un peu de viande du bon légumes des
caravanes avaient des poireaux à branne
céleri 1 bouquet garni et en automne
comment faire un bouillon je m trois
louches oui la haye maintenant on aime
faire passer le verbe divin roue et on
verra après oui et on va voir après ce
qui manquera donc pour recouvrir cette
viande et contrairement aux autres prend
le goût de pas et bien là il faut un
litre un bon litre j'en ai je trouve
même rajouté dit oui et oui parce que
c'est pas tout gamin et je vais même
rajouté des brouilleurs les envolées ses
cuirs couvert bien entendu oui voilà
deux louches de bouillon et c'est bon et
maïté maintenant quand même vous me dire
on va laisser cuire mais tout n'est pas
terminé parce que que va-t-on faire avec
les fruits et les champignons
il faut peler les poires une chacune une
chacune en laissant la queue en laissant
la queue
sans l'abîmer bon alors on ne sait pas
de concours de vitesse dans ce cas là
pour faire bien voir ce que vous allez
faire plus vite comme moi sont là où je
suis sur quoi si on veut vraiment aussi
jolie c'est pour joli match à regarder
vous avez deux fois plus vite que moi ça
c'est pouvoir voir un bon oui vous avez
coupé regarder ça c'est chez vous et
vous n'avez pas la coupe et remet au
sort on la laisse un tiers et on va la
retrouver en tire dans l'âme et dans la
sauce et vous savez ce sera joli après
voilà elle va cuire dans le jus c'est
bien mais ça y est ce que ceci vous va
comme ça un joli bon méchoui les bravos
alors on va continuer nous allons ouvrir
dans la science on va baigner dans la
voile et ensuite bon nos réserves
alors les réserves encore un tout de
suite je sais pas lequel des deux mais
sur bien m'a serré et gonflé dans une
allemagne à los angeles et l'armagnac
servent à cacher
alors on va mettre nos réserves comme
ceci la voilà tout obama's et pillages
et ensuite les champignons alors vous
allez mettre comme dans ces champignons
ils ont été bien entendu l'avait on a
vrillé là que oui on a et on les laisse
entiers entier et on impose pareil ça
fait un bons légumes rei tout sauf le
légume volet raclée un peu de sous la
halle aux grains qui sont ouverts ouais
bon voilà on a cinq ou six quelque chose
comme ça hein
allez regardez moi ça si ça fait joli et
voilà le dernier devient voire très bien
qu est ce que t il à éviter quand même
ses pruneaux on va pas les mettre avec
leur noyau oui meilleur label warp
levier noyauté comment fait on en veut à
la pointe d'un couteau
tout simplement parce que c'est pas tout
simplement c'est pas si facile parce que
le noyau est très accroché à la chaire
l'annoncé symbole eh ben oui on avait
dit qu'on pouvait les trouver tout
dénoyautées qu'est ce qu'on s'en tient
quand même là oui ça par quoi il faut
dire qu'ils sont jeunes ils sont bien
gras ouais les temps ont des sags et ça
c'est bien donc voilà très bien et alors
après ça vous avez vraiment des ailes
dans la sens je vais me remettre dans 2
s'est tous dit oui où tous les autres
q gentiment on peut y aller je crois la
trêve hivernale quand même suffisamment
la poêle là c'est bien aussi difficile
encore à faire regardez moi ça c'est ce
joli et bien ça c'est bien la regarder
vous à imaginer tous les fruits qu'il ya
là dedans mais oui c'est très très
vieille recette vous savez en mettez
beaucoup de choses pour donner beaucoup
de goût parce que peut-être que les
viandes avait vraiment bon bout
autrefois voile adhérer mais voilà bon
et maintenant maïté combien de temps
tous avant je vais ouvrir mais il faut
bien mijoter à feu doux deux heures de
temps et c'est tout non je vais préparer
ma petite mixture là pour finir la sauce
oui mais ça le devoir a pu raconter ce
que vous faites là expliquez-vous h et
le x e h le four du la peur ça sera
réservé pour nier
voilà alors je mets ce soir dans le
petit bol qui se trouve là oui voilà
et je vais mélanger le sens où il ya eu
déjà du vinaigre pour l'empêcher de
calais voile alors je mets tout ça je
revue et je vais me lié ma sauce avec sa
valeur autrement dit dans la cocotte
tour va aller voir ça mijote depuis 2h
n'y aura plus qu'à servir
on va voir une fois que j'aurais ajouté
le foie et le ca il faut plus que ça
bout et ça va être difficile parce que
ça bout rien là non non mais vous allez
voir je vais aller tendre le foot techno
et j'étais en suivant ces jolies lattes
2 1
n'est ce pas et je vois la poire je vois
les pruneaux tous a pris une couleur
voilà une heureuse bien réduite et jared
n'y a plus qu'à servir terminé il ne
reste plus qu'à servir ce plat et à le
déguster
c'est une sorte de civet nous font pas
tout à fait quand même parce qu'avec les
fruits oui c'est différent quand c'est
différent c'est différent c'est une très
ancienne recette
oui tiens de maïté aurez de la chance de
la trouver voyez dans les papiers
rouillé il faut jamais rien jeter en
cuisine mais jamais rien à jeter de ce
qu'on trouve dans les placards des
grands mères j'ai entendu dire ça
souvent eh ben oui parce qu'on trouve
des surprises agréables là alors là vous
êtes en train de retrouver les pruneaux
larry wah wah les noirs les blé brunot
les champignons
toutes ces choses minitieuse l'a bien
mijoté bien réduit où ça changeait de
couleur
oui voilà eh ben ça a l'air bien bon et
puis non lapin nos amis du début de
l'émission ils sont toujours là hein
alors où le monde peut voir on ne les a
pas tué ils sont restés avec nous ils
sont tous beaux elles vont bientôt aller
courir dans leurs prairies n'est ce pas
voilà oui voilà vous pouvez regarder
c'est bon c'est pas pour vous pour le
manger mais c'est bon il a le nez qui
remuent comme s'ils sont aidés dans le
bas-rhin et bien voilà mais il est bien
content aussi de repartir chez lui et
puis voyez ça c'est une recette quand
même il ya du sucré du salé quand même
est sale et ça existe déjà d'ailleurs
autres depuis longtemps les
l'espace est très très très près ce
dossier on a toujours mélangé les fruits
avec des produits sains exactement
l'alcool la preuve qu ont inventorié
rendent excellent accusé de moder donc
autrefois faisait aussi et bien à vous
d'essayer il ya rien de plus facile
un petit peu de patience deux heures ou
s'amuser tout seul à lire bien plus
facile à bientôt au revoir merci et bon
appétit
[Musique]